die bürgermeister sind für mich so ein
bisschen der lichtblick in dieser corona
krise weil sie mit ihrem engagement ganz
oft ausgleichen was über ihn in
irgendwelchen behörden viel langsamer
träge bräsig leucht und einer von diesen
bürgermeistern ist christian von
waldenfels mit dem ich jetzt sprechen
möchte nicht irgendein bürgermeister
sondern der jüngste bürgermeister
deutschlands er regiert mit seinen
gerade mal 20 jahren in der gemeinde
lichtenberg in oberfranken schönen guten
tag herr von waldenfels hallo herr weise
ich empfinde die deutsche politik und
die deutsche verwaltung gerade in dieser
krise als total breese ich warum was ist
ihre erklärung warum es deutschland zu
preisen
ich habe in letzter zeit den eindruck
dass vieles daran liegt dass sich ämter
und verschiedene verantwortung in
unserer gesellschaft tragende nicht in
dem maße miteinander austauschen wie sie
das unbedingt sollten
man hat doch den eindruck dass dann der
letzte die letzte meile vielleicht
manchmal fehlt der wille ist da es wird
viel gesprochen aber und auch gute
ansätze sind da aber es fehlt die letzte
war das letzte quäntchen das dann dinge
zum erfolg führen kann